let's jump to this next story which is
not about guns but is about the
Department of Justice from The
Tennessean doj challenges Tennessee's
ban on transgender care for minors the
first thing I want to say is I take
issue with the title of this article so
I'm going to rephrase it for the sake of
honesty
Department of Justice challenges
Tennessee's ban on child sex change
surgery I mean you laugh but like
language is a huge component of how the
left plays politics absolutely and this
is this is exactly what was banned they
don't want medications Purity blockers
hormones and surgery for children
so these children have to you know be
adults before making these decisions but
now that doj has announced that they are
going to under the 14th Amendment try
and block this ban from happening
they argue
sb1 the bill makes it unlawful to
provide or offer to provide certain
types of medical care for transgender
minors with diagnosed gender dysphoria
sb1's blanket ban prohibits potential
treatment options that have been
recommended by Major Medical
associations for consideration in
limited circumstances in accordance with
established and comprehensive guidelines
Etc et cetera by denying only
transgender youth access to these forms
of medically necessary care while
allowing non-tran transgender miners
access to the same or similar procedures
what there's always did you catch that
but let me read it it discriminates
against transgender youth the doj is
arguing that non-trans kids are
undergoing sex change surgery well if
that's the case we got a bigger problem
than just this one bill there are
caveats to most people including
Tennessee's that say children who were
born with a you know genetic defect they
don't identify a chance there's
literally something wrong there intersex
there's another issue at play they can
get hormonal treatment or something like
that but those people are not in the
same sphere as I'm not sure right and
it's it's determined by very much by
their genetics and their biology as
opposed to their psychological condition
like how often does that I mean and I
don't know I haven't studied this how
often does that actually happen you know
we talking like a 0.000 rare I mean it's
very uncommon it makes sense intersex
kids or kids were born with like xxy I
think it's like .0017 or something but
it makes sense to permit them
finishingly small right but they want to
use that to argue well we should do it
for every one it's like well now that
we're seeing tens of thousands of kids
undergoing procedures of some sort uh
over the past few years it's getting
into like this I think it's 60 or so
thousand we went over this when Destiny
was here yeah 40 some odd thousand
taking hormone cross-sex hormones or
puberty blockers and then it's in the
thousands of uh uh teenage girls who are
getting mastectomies can you imagine if
a country uh foreign Europe they're
banning it if a foreign country in the
future say in 10 years and we've got
just all this stuff going on I was like
we're gonna invade America to free the
oppressed and get rid of this stuff
that's destroying kids and a foreign
Nation wanted to invade us over that
wouldn't that be fascinating you know if
I was going to look at history and
you're going to look at an invasion or
something if a foreign Invader let's say
it was like I don't know
European nation sure we'll call it like
a water uh call it Germany they're good
at it let's just say there's like let's
just say there's like a big land mass in
the in in Europe and it started by water
and then maybe there's like a smaller
landmass to the west and then people
from One go to the other and then say
like you can't have kids anymore and you
can't speak your language one way to you
know get rid of that lineage just to
stop them from having kids avoiding
their kids or sterilizing their kids yep
that's one thing so when I see this this
is why I keep saying like it really does
feel like Democrats hate their own
constituents because like if you went to
someone and said have you considered
sterilizing your children it sounds like
you're insulting them I think there's a
deep nihilism that comes from most of
the philosophies that come from the left
I think that there is a a real
significant dislike of humanity the
whole uh environmental movement I feel
like is anti-human
um a lot of the left I feel like is
anti-human so it it when you say stuff
like that it doesn't sound like you're
talking about something crazy it's it
fits right in with my kind of concept of
the way the left thinks you know it
comes from the same sphere of uh
Humanity that produces articles that's
like here are 30 women who talk about
why they regret having children and it's
like selfish reasons I will point out
that the how great my abortion was yeah
exactly like it you don't want to be
with these people anyways but I will
point out that the the doj sued Alabama
for similar reasons Alabama has uh
Senate Bill uh 184 and it's effectively
very similar right it's restricting the
medical procedures that you can offer
children who identify as transgender and
they classify it as part of their push
to prevent a gender-based discrimination
and I find this to be such a blatant
show of activism they sued Alabama in
April of 2022 and you can't you have to
wonder like
who is backing this like can you I guess
like I have never really liked the
federal government so it's easy for me
to say like we should let the states
regulate them on their own but on the
left
are you really that interested in
authoritarianism where you can have a
justice department that just actively
tries to selectively push its agenda
like at what point does that become
appealing to someone when you're growing
up when do you start thinking like you
know what I really want a really strong
central government that promotes a uh an
ideology that destroys children I don't
think that the government I think the
government is uh is a necessary from
their perspective the government is a
necessary evil to achieve the ends that
they're looking for and they don't think
about the fact that when you empower the
government it's you never you know just
continues to amass power it's not going
to give power back so
seems crazy to me the other part that I
find interesting is that the the doj put
out the statement saying like this is a
terrible thing to do especially for
transgender identifying youth or they
say transgender youth but uh who are
already at risk of suicide depression
Etc and then the Tennessee uh uh
attorney general his office put out
statement saying like actually no this
is not a conform a confirmed way to
treat children in fact having them go
through these treatments can increase
suicide anxiety and depression and so
they're at this Crossroads where you
know we really don't know what to do
with this issue and so you can kind of
argue the same thing and end up on
different ends same screen two different
movies like Scott Adams says Lucas I
mean you're from Tennessee do you is
there an app a significant appetite for
this stuff around Nashville do you feel
like there's a lot of people that are
like so or does it seem like this stuff
is coming out of nowhere and there's not
like a lot of support for it it does
seem like something that comes out of
nowhere uh I'm not a real big conspiracy
theorist but what when all this stuff
came is you know is being talked about
none of this is shocking to me and the
reason this isn't shocking to me is for
the last 50 years it's everyone has been
been desensitized to being okay with
murdering babies I did something like 63
million I think is what I wrote down I
was doing some research earlier today 63
million babies have been aboard in the
last 50 years just here in our country
wow so over 50 years people have been
desensitized to it's okay it's
acceptable we can do it at four weeks
six weeks eight weeks um I think someone
was telling me it was either the West
Virginia governor a couple years ago was
saying after uh after the baby was born
or is Virginia governor Virginia and um
and so with all this trans stuff about
kids if if people don't value their
children before they're born why would
they value their children but the
abortion thing is important to point out
the 63 million it was probably like 63
million Democrats you know what I mean I
mean but I mean but but you know it's
not meant to be snide or rude or funny
sure to make the point like
those are the people doing it that's 63
million votes gone in 20 years the
Democratic party yeah and that means
that the the politics around abortion is
going to change no questions I mean
people on the right side yeah but
they're trying to adapt and document our
kids and I'm like yes but you're aware
of that
so as long as you're aware and you're
resisting it then right likelihood they
change they convert your kids into being
you know anti-baby well very low well
and the trans thing too I mean I've I've
only seen a few um you know stories come
out of of kids afterwards who say they
regret you know you read it it's a lot
honestly it's probably the most sad
depressing thing I ever see are the
stories of those kids were like I can
never get this back I made this decision
or my parents had me make this decision
I can't do anything and I feel like oh
in the next like five years those are
gonna blow up there's going to be a lot
more of those or the suicide rate's
going to go up even more so at what
point are people really going to ask the
question or are they going to squish all
those stories we just keep doing it
we've seen it before I mean we we've had
there have been practices that have been
banned lobotomies are banned they they
would go to people and say I think the
appropriate treatment for your child is
for us to remove a portion of their
frontal lobe through their nose or
something like that and then they would
turn their kids into zombies wasn't
there like a Kennedy yeah it's Rosemary
Kennedy she's the first daughter so it
was Joe John and then Rosemary and she
had they believe like didn't have enough
oxygen when she was born she always had
add some sort of brain disorder and it
became progressively worse and her
parents eventually heard like hey
there's this cool new treatment it might
be able to help and they were desperate
I mean I think everyone looking back
recognizes how wrong they were but when
you don't have the information I could
understand right yeah but even then
there was enough I mean I think at the
time when she had her lobotomy it was
only like a hundred people had undergone
them which like she already seems like
too many but again if you didn't know
and if they're as they were
misrepresenting the results of these
things I mean I understand wanting to
help who you love and especially if
you're desperate but I think it's
obvious in this case that waiting is the
best course of action right offering
other forms of therapy and really
discussing with your child like what's
going on is so much safer than saying
take these drugs alter your body well
and I also feel like I saw a video I
think it was Jordan Peterson he posted
earlier today of and and this obviously
isn't happening for everyone but it's
probably happening more than people want
to admit there was this a a bunch of
tick tock videos of his dad with his
trans daughter and the report was that
he was using her for uh likes and
attention yeah and uh that right there
uh it has all sorts of problems with it
but I I would be curious how many
parents are doing going through with
this to keep up with the Joneses yeah it
is now the new thing oh yeah my kids
trans too yours is too hey I'm doing
this you know and I mean it's just a
pawn Bill Barr mentions it we're seeing
it in California but not Ohio so either
there's something happening in the water
in Colorado in California or they're
they're socializing their kids this way
well and during covid when uh students
went home there were all these anecdotal
reports about we used to have you know
six identifying uh trans identifying
students and now it's only one of them a
bunch of them decided when they were
home with their families that they
didn't actually feel this way right like
of course the anecdotal I'd love to see
hard numbers on it but there is
something to be said for the social
contagion aspect of it I think you're
totally right I missed the days of the
tiger mom when it's like all these women
trying to make their kids be the best of
whatever like instead of trying to make
your kid a different gender can't you
just like stress them out about getting
good grades not that that's a healthy
way to pair it but yeah thanks thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time